seitdem 2007 das iphone vorgestellt
wurde ist der touchscreen zum
universalen werkzeug geworden handy
tablet laptop geld abheben oder
fahrkarten kaufen alles funktioniert
heute mit einem touchscreen
aber wird das auch so bleiben oder gibt
es bald bessere methoden um unsere
geräte zu steuern
dieser touchscreen sieht zwar aus wie
jeder normale touchscreen vibriert aber
mit einer ultraschall frequenz durch die
unglaublich schnelle bewegung des
bildschirms entsteht unter dem finger
ein dünnes luftpolster und der finger
kann leichter über die oberfläche
gleiten
je nachdem wie schnell der touchscreen
vibriert rutscht man besser oder eben
schlechter über die oberfläche
schnellere vibrationen sorgen für mehr
luft die bewegt wird und somit für eine
glattere oberfläche umgekehrt führen
geringere oder sogar gar keine
frequenzen wenn das tablet ausgeschaltet
ist zu einer eher haftenden oberfläche
durch diesen trick bekommt man das
gefühl von texturen und einem haptischen
feedback obwohl der bildschirm aus ganz
normalem glas besteht anwenden könnte
man diese technik in fast jeder app um
mehr sinne anzusprechen und somit mehr
informationen weiterzugeben
project soul i ist eines der neuesten
projekte von google mit hilfe von radar
wählen wird eine hand im
dreidimensionalen raum getrennt
das funktioniert sogar ohne dass man
irgendetwas berühren muss die entwickler
von project soul i versprechen dass
diese methode sehr präzise sein und man
damit kleinste gesten und finger
bewegungen wahrnehmen und erkennen könne
die ganze magie passiert nur in diesem
kleinen chip der auf ein fast genauso
kleines wort passt wenn die technologie
ausgereifter ist könnte man den radar
chip in beinahe jedes gerät einbauen von
laptops über smartphones bis hin zu
klein smart watch ist gehst mit unserer
hand und mit unseren fingern sind für
uns viel natürlicher als auf einer
glasoberfläche herum zu wischen und so
könnte projekt sony bald die art und
weise verändern wie wir mit alltäglichen
geräten arbeiten an der stanford
universität entwickelt ein team gerade
einen controller der die gefühle des
spielers wahrnehmen kann
mit bionischen sensoren am controller
kann man herzfrequenz körpertemperatur
und sogar acht nun messen und somit
herausfinden was der spieler gerade
fühlt dazu braucht man gar keine die
juden am kopf zu tragen
die hautoberfläche erzählt bereits viel
darüber was im inneren eines körpers
vorgeht wenn dem spieler zb langweilig
wird und die herzfrequenz sinkt dann
könnte man das spiel zu programmieren
dass automatisch mehr zombies
losgelassen werden auf den spieler
zugeschnittene spielsequenzen können den
spielspaß um einiges erhöhen und die
daten darüber wie gamer reagieren könnte
den spieleentwicklern wiederum helfen
ihr gang zu verbessern
das sind nur einige wenige möglichkeiten
die unser leben verändern können
welche eingabe techniken gibt es noch
was haltet ihr für vielversprechend und
was ist nur ein gimmick diskutiert das
wie immer mit mir unten in den
kommentaren zu den beiden letzten folgen
von watson kommt ihr hier kann es
wirklich hammer box geben war das letzte
video ein video das jetzt noch viel
relevanter geworden ist nach dem lexus
ein wirklich echtes hammer ort
präsentiert und gezeigt hat und das
video davor hyper luke der schnellste
zug der welt der bald flugzeuge ersetzen
könnte wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann gebt mir einen daumen nach oben
ansonsten zeigt mir was ich besser
machen kann ansonsten viel spaß und bis
zum nächsten mal